if i can locate other mandalorians
i thought you said you weren't the
gambler
[Music]
thank the force this
little thing has had me worried sick
come near you little whomp rat
[Laughter]
looks like it remembers me how much do
you want for it just kidding but not
really
i figure only one of us walking out of
here but then i see the little guy
take it off or i will
we gonna do this in front of the kid
he's seen worse
oh
[Music]
here it's yours
[Music]
i thought you said you vouched for her
on your life
no no no no no that
is not food don't do that again
no no i told you not to do that
how many did you eat
i suspect the temperature will drop
significantly when night falls
i recommend you get some sleep
i thought honoring one's word was a part
of the mandalorian code
i guess those are just stories for
children
how about you come over here give me a
hand make yourself useful
hey kid
no no
[Music]
right
[Music]
wow
others with vesgar have been through
here
don't play with your food
you would help me by creed
so i want you to be respectful and mind
your manners
you know what i'm talking about
[Music]
come on it's time to go let go come on
kid
congratulations
no i have enough pens
oh
you